foreign
[Music]
of monsters it was only recently that
the first King Kong movie which
premiered in movie theaters 90 years ago
on March 2nd 1933 celebrated its
anniversary so what could be more
appropriate than to talk about his next
big appearance in legendary so-called
monsterverse after the mighty ape
finally met the radioactive giant lizard
in 2021's Godzilla vs Kong today we
devote ourselves to the upcoming sequel
Godzilla vs Kong 2 which will be
released in cinemas in 2024. we wish you
lots of fun with our new original
episode
legendary's monsterverse is one of the
most profitable movie series in recent
years so far it includes 2014's Godzilla
2017's Kong Skull Island 2019's Godzilla
2 King Of Monsters And of course
Godzilla vs Kong the four movies
together gross nearly 2 billion dollars
that's remarkable considering that
Godzilla vs Kong was released in the
midst of the pandemic and hence at a
time of a very struggling movie industry
the fact that audiences still flock to
theaters demonstrates the franchise's
immense popularity it's only natural
that the producers want to build on this
success as we already know from the
original synopsis Godzilla vs Kong 2
follows on directly from the story of
its predecessor for this reason we
should first recall everything that
actually happened in part one as the
plot is definitely more complex than
that of many other monster action movies
be aware that there's a high risk of
spoilers for those of you who haven't
seen the first part yet the plot of
Godzilla vs Kong is set five years after
the victory of Godzilla over the
Extraterrestrial Dragon King Ghidorah on
Skull Island King Kong awakens under the
close watch of Monarch scientist Dr
Eileen Andrews he forms a bond with
young Jia who's a member of the iwi
tribe and also Eileen's foster daughter
the two disagree on how to deal with the
giant ape as releasing it would probably
bring Godzilla the king of the Titans to
the scene meanwhile far away from Skull
Island Godzilla is up to no good and
Attacks An ex-employee of Apex
cybernetics unprovoked in the process
they also come across signs of the
hollow Earth theory there are even
energy signals and indications of an
ecosystem of its own despite Eileen's
hesitation King Kong is finally loaded
onto a ship she fears that he might
clash with Godzilla as was the case with
their ancestors Kong who was chained on
the ship becomes increasingly anxious
and communicates this to the deaf Gia by
sign language it doesn't take long for
Godzilla to make his way to the heavily
guarded Convoy and knock over Kong's
ship the first epic Clash between the
two ensues for Kong is freed from his
shackles during the attack and
immediately battles Godzilla by means of
a trick the ship's crew manages to
deceive the vastly superior Godzilla
causing him to leave meanwhile the
energy signal is measurable in
Antarctica and Kong is supposed to lead
the team to the origin of the Titans
there he makes his way through a tunnel
in a portal where the world of the
Titans finally appears to them the
hollow Earth theory has been confirmed
after Kong fights off some other Titans
he grabs his ancestors ax with this he's
a lot stronger than before as the ax can
use the mysterious energy of the hollow
Earth back on the Earth's surface the
second fight between Kong and Godzilla
occurs this time however things look
much more balanced thanks to the ax
nevertheless Godzilla is still the more
powerful and Remains the alpha leader it
soon becomes clear that both must work
together for a final fight and that the
proverbial Hatchet must be buried after
all the Shady Apex Corporation has been
working for years on its own Titan with
which they want to secure the supremacy
among the giant monsters on Earth the
Mecha Godzilla the teamwork finally pays
off and Mechagodzilla is defeated in an
epic final battle you can also see the
Titans parting on good terms after
winning the fight and paying respect to
one another the final scene of the movie
shows Kong in the hollow Earth and
Godzilla going back to Earth this
implies that both of effective rulers of
their own realm and thus won't get in
each other's way one can tell from this
ending that it could certainly be seen
as a final conclusion this is also
pointed out by director Adam Wingard who
is stressed in the past that a conscious
decision was made not to choose an
overly open ending if some kind of
cliffhanger had been built in everyone
would only be talking about what's to
come and not about the movie itself
now we want to discuss the possible
storyline of the long announced sequel
if some leaks are to be believed the new
adversary of Godzilla and Kong has
already been revealed it is said to be
the so-called space Godzilla which first
appeared in the 1994 film Godzilla vs
Space Godzilla by Touhou visually the
two look confusingly similar even though
space Godzilla is considerably stronger
than his counterpart from Earth he also
scores with an above average
intelligence which gives him an
additional advantage in the fight
against other Titans he uses clever
tactical Maneuvers for example to come
out victorious in most battles his
personality is also fundamentally
different from other Titans apart from
the fact that he is one of the strongest
representatives of his kind he's also
characterized by a Sly malicious nature
a controversial matter is the origin and
backstory of space Godzilla while it is
known that he is a clone of the real
Godzilla it is not known how his DNA got
into space one theory is that parts of
Godzilla's genetic material were
accidentally dispersed into space by
Mothra where it took on a life of its
own and eventually led to the creation
of space Godzilla through a black or
white hole respectively this version is
also used in Godzilla vs Space Godzilla
but the story was slightly altered in
the Godzilla toys made by Trend Masters
here they talk about space Godzilla
being a hybrid of Godzilla and the alien
by atlante the latter had a crystalline
form which in turn explains the gigantic
crystals on Space Godzilla's body by the
way biolante is also a creature that was
originally created from Godzilla's DNA
so it's not yet possible to accurately
predict which direction will be taken in
Godzilla vs Kong 2. it is also
questionable how space Godzilla will fit
into the current monsterverse should
indeed be the main villain Adam Wingard
who returned to his role as director
already talked about the rough direction
of Godzilla vs Kong 2 in an interview
with deadline two years ago having
already introduced The Hollow Earth the
sequel will probably explore this place
in more detail they might delve into the
history of this mysterious location and
tell the story of the Titans especially
how they came to Earth in the first
place it is possible that at the
beginning of Godzilla vs Kong 2 there
will again be a clash between the two
protagonists as we know the two-parted
peacefully however we still can't speak
of a really amicable relationship rumor
has it that a comradly coexistence could
be disturbed by the introduction of a
fellow species of King Kong this fits
well with the repeatedly rumored
possible title son of Kong which already
points to more than just one giant ape
this ape may want to take revenge on
Godzilla and cause great chaos in the
hollow Earth in the original synopsis
that Warner Brothers published last year
there is only talk of a new common enemy
that Godzilla and Kong can only defeat
as one in addition a more detailed
explanation of the history of Skull
Island and the general background of
Kong and Godzilla's existence is hinted
at thus there are indeed some Clues to
the plot of the officially still
Untitled Godzilla vs Kong sequel
nevertheless many story details have
been deliberately kept under wraps so
far by the way it will not stop at one
sequel several films based on the
previous monsterverse have been planned
so it's quite conceivable that this film
will also lay the groundwork for further
sequels with currently 32 Japanese
Godzilla films there should be plenty of
inspiration in any case
production on Godzilla vs Kong 2 has
been ongoing for quite some time shortly
after the successful release of Godzilla
vs Kong there were initial statements
from those responsible that implied a
sequel then nearly a year ago it was
announced that filming would start a few
months later on the Australian Gold
Coast and in the region of Southeast
Queensland it was likewise quickly
announced that director Adam Wingard had
once again been chosen to direct the
movie and that Downton Abbey star Dan
Stevens will be playing the lead role
later on it was revealed that actors
Rebecca Hall Brian Tyree Henry and
Kaylee hoddle as Gia would make a
comeback they'll be joined by Irma VAP
actress Fala Chen EastEnders actor
Alexander Ferns and Rachel house who can
currently be seen in the Australian
comedy series heartbreak High filming
took place between June and November
2022 meaning that post-production is
currently in full progress at the end of
July footage from the set attracted a
lot of attention showing people fleeing
from a beach based on this there will
probably be at least one scene in the
film that takes place on the Copacabana
in Rio de Janeiro shortly after the end
of filming a new title for the film was
circular sitting on the internet namely
Godzilla and Kong whether or not this
will eventually be the actual name of
the film has not been officially
confirmed as of yet the sequel is
expected to be released in cinemas on
March 15 2024
now you know all the essential
information about the upcoming Godzilla
vs Kong sequel don't forget to share
your theories about the monster
Blockbuster in the comments and let us
know what you think of the monsterverse
so far thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]